كرسي واله القهوه طويله ومعدله مطبخيه
ليست اثاث بيت يريد اصحابه الهجره بل هي
مقتنيات اكبر الشركات التكنولوجيه في
العالم الطاقه الحرب تويتر بعد انعازف عنه
اثر التغييرات التي اجراها الملك الجديد
دولار تعرض 636 قطعه من مبداها في
كاليفورنيا على الموقع
امانه القهوه التي لطالب استخدمها
الموظفون سجلت احد عشر الف دولار هذا
الشعار البسيط الذي قد يمر به الموظفون
يوميا وهم غير بوجود تجاوز ثمنه ثمانيه
الف دولار
مبالغ لم تحل ازمه تويتر الماليه الا انها
على مبدا القليل قد يسند الحال
[موسيقى]
لمسك الذي عجز عن دفع ايجار الشركه ما
تسبب برفع الدعوه والقضائيه عليه في الوقت
الذي يحاول فيه مالك الطائر الازرق يخفض
النفقات بشكل كبير
ويزيد الدخل باي وسيله